these markers covering the map each one
of those represents one mass shooting
incident that's defined as being four or
more people injured or killed in the
u.s. these attacks since 2013 those red
markers there represent more than one
incident in that particular area and
while this is already quite a shocking
picture it's likely to be an incomplete
list now the killing of 49 people at the
LGBTQ pulse nightclub in Florida on
Saturday night has become the deadliest
mass shooting in US history
investigations as we know are continuing
but authorities believe that Omar
matine's actions may have been inspired
in part by foreign terror organizations
now just take a closer look here at the
fatalities because were team killed more
people during this attack than all the
previous jihadis despite air attacks on
US soil since 9/11 combined but in
contrast to the 9/11 hijackers the vast
majority of those found have been
involved in jihadist inspired attacks or
plots in the u.s. since September the
11th have been u.s. born or naturalized
citizens well being a US citizen himself
Mateen was legally able to purchase one
of these an ar-15 type assault weapon
despite being twice interviewed by the
FBI for statements he made about ties to
terrorists now this particular weapon is
capable of firing up to 45 rounds per
minute it costs about a thousand dollars
and it requires no waiting period in
Florida this is the type of weapon that
was also used to kill 14 people during
the San Bernardino shooting late last
year and also to shoot dead twenty
children and six adults during the Sandy
Hook school massacre
well estimates vary as to exactly how
many of these are in circulation but it
is the most popular rifle in the US are
thought to be around 3.75 million in
circulation to put that into context
it's still only around about 1% of the
357 million guns thought to be in
circulation in the u.s. that's the
equivalent of more than one per man
woman or child on average in the US